Hausa comb rest my name is purity back
welcome to another episode of Walking
Dead Season well I got a achievement for
accounting [ __ ] here what and you just
believed her you should have put her out
of her misery right there shooter
everybody just calm down for a second
I'm not working for anyone
oh I don't know what you're talking
about I just need help we got a doctor
right here okay he'll have a look no
what the hell is wrong with you people
okay she's just scared we're all scared
Luke don't act like we're the ones being
irrational cuz we don't buy this
[ __ ] story oh wait she survived out
here on her own why are we even arguing
about this let me take a look hi
catalyst finally a nice character why
come on trust him it's okay go ahead
he's a doctor
you know that must've hurt
well claim is about A's whatever it was
it got you good
this isn't how we do things man when
you're bit you get put down end of story
I'm not going through this again no
one's suggesting that we could take her
arm off no no that ain't no hands we can
try that it won't do any good
you'll just be making it worse for the
girl it's crazy
no one's going to volunteer to do that I
would puppy eyes always works there they
are
how can you say no to those kid no need
for a guilt trip Lucy Sarah what I say
stay inside
[Music]
help me and Ellie I don't mean to be any
trouble
I just want to stop the bleeding and
then I'll go you'll never see me again I
promise
and where exactly would you go
my friend is out there find my friend
Krista forget it you won't get by beep
look I may be in the minority here but
my gut tells me she's telling the truth
it probably is just a dog bite probably
you didn't say that before men so what
do you think what's the worker a bite
like that could be anything only one way
to find out how wait wait
dad Wayman by tomorrow morning if the
fever set in we'll know if she's gonna
turn in the meantime we can lock her in
the shed
what about my arm it needs to get
cleaned and stitched and bandaged the
curl is in bad shape Carlos we have all
that stuff inside the cap we could
probably get rowdy we but yeah okay
supplies on a lurker bike it turns out
you're telling the truth I'll clean it
stitch it up for you in the morning
but that's harsh man but I guess it I'm
sorry that's the best we're gonna get
[Music]
finger off the trigger son thanks son
don't move like that man it's all right
boys got his mom's temper come on
this is just a waste of time you'll see
and when she turned I [ __ ] Vince I
think we should say with Emily are
really hurt I don't know what to tell
you except hold out the best you can
we'll see what we can do in the morning
if I make it until then maybe you could
get me some supplies I wish I could I
really do but it's too risky
sorry I'm just gonna lock me in
[Music]
I've got his [ __ ] flying man look at
that
[Music]
because it's safer this way and I'd
rather be sure
I can't believe this phone Lily was
there now you're gonna be fine we're
gonna escape right we're not just gonna
[ __ ] sit around and [ __ ] all right
let's look for the least obvious stuff
because it is always like pegboard
tackle boxes good thing not much left in
here I guess if I have to I can use this
for stitches damn that's way to think
that's sharp clam I don't know what
you're trying to pull here and I don't
like that look of yours
I just once it's sweet boy I don't know
what they're called in English oh that's
something up there hammer what are you
what are you gonna do what I came ago oh
well then we're using it now
and here a table well that's really nice
and that's Miami now Oh clam is having a
bad day that's all I'm saying let's try
and make this better
okay so wait I have a hammer we have a
sharp object and we have a barrel for
some [ __ ] reason
hello barrel I think to say hey oh okay
and here we can use hammer to use get
the spikes now we're trying to escape is
that it foot double fight so we're gonna
sneak in and get supplies is that it
[Music]
whoa we have a doctor he's gotta have
stuff her stitches what's that on the
roof our branches Oh
Sammis they live nearby the Sammis find
a way into the cabin and obtain a needle
peroxide and some bandages okay now this
would be the obvious way right let's
check the windows first there's an open
window but it's too tall
we can use this and go underneath we
need the hammer though do we have it
all right mrs. Amer well that was easy
stealth assassin climb doin a
would you brothers really do it I think
I would just try to stay in and survive
but Clem Clem is not a person like me I
guess should we wait the knife should do
it though I'll did it break oh no well I
guess we don't need it anymore
careful now climbing close here for
laughing Amy
we're probably gonna meet up with the
girl yeah we're not gonna go in there
right how we are okay well fine what do
I know about life
okay where do they keep their medical
supplies let's listen that's one sweet
ass fish there's no way she's out of
your body
right whoever she's with they'll
probably come looking for her great they
show up we've got her life you think we
should bring her in here no I'm just
saying it wouldn't look
uh-huh it's just a precautionary measure
anyone else would do the same who's
Carver exactly I come on I want at the
handed Amara well I guess I got a bank
am don't want to eavesdrop too much okay
okay I know where to go
let's be careful now claiming stealth
sizing claim it's gonna climb on your I
don't even know anymore bathroom yeah
yeah I keep stuff in the bathroom right
hopefully no one is taking a [ __ ]
score all right let's check the medicine
cabinet
a tomato god damn it
Annie no we'll need that perfect thanks
tomato nevermind clean still need some
bandages something to keep it from
getting infected alcohol and toilet
paper have to have medical supplies
around here somewhere
now what is it oh oh oh oh God it's a
bad spot
Oh God we're gonna watch her pee I don't
want to do that just need to have this
be are you high
let it be okay that may be his
what
what is happening toilet did you see
that [ __ ] get it
what if okay let it be his we're fine
it's gotta be careful those candles are
identical to that one's downstairs
bedroom it's too easy bedroom
bingo
well they sure like kennels don't they
don't they know they're not supposed to
leave a room with a candle lit I swear
that's like the first rule ever rights
check the wardrobe it's long
Oh what not exactly bandages but they
should help stop the bleeding
oh okay now we just need alcohol
Oh peroxide
well [ __ ] do I know about medical
supplies where would you keep that
probably in the adults person's bedroom
behind a drawer hidden I don't know I
don't one in each room that's kind of
ironic that doorknob oh yeah hey I just
met you and I'm not supposed to be in
here don't make a sound okay I'm just
trying to fix my arm
what do you want peroxide I need your
help and meth
what are you reading you reading but
what book I like books it's called the
gurgler it's about transdimensional
body-snatchers cool what happened to you
a dog bit me a dog bit me
and it hurts
I could die if I don't take care of it
do you understand I just need something
to clean it with I bet it would be with
the rest of your medical supplies where
is it Jaime I'm Clementine we're friends
right we can be best bad Oh God god no
ah please no guys just met you we're not
friends
oh god oh god stop talking please
okay we're friends yes we're friends
promise oh god I don't like making empty
promises oh come on
[Music]
I'll get this when I get it
thank you
oh is that bad book is flying holy [ __ ]
we have to go back to the shed right
you're not gonna say thanks really
clammy I thought I'd taught you manners
there you go
[ __ ] shut up all right well the shed
should be saying it's safe right we're
gonna get caught aren't we
no no it doesn't make sense we made it
way too much effort to get caught now
that is one ugly couch where was it here
it was yeah you minute unless something
happens please don't happen yeah baby
yeah
they were playing poker on the table
that's funny good old shade now time to
do have you boys ever got stitches
apparently by the light of the moon
right now but that's the only place I
got it but by own gentleman doctor I was
in skiing and [ __ ] and then I hit my
head because I wasn't drunk
I probably will hi ma'am well without
padam and I I don't [ __ ] know English
anymore okay it's a first you must pour
a little sploosh
does that really happen okay I'm good
I'm fine
[ __ ] I remember when I did that I was
like the most painful [ __ ] ever worse
than taking like the largest no stitches
yes citrus focus oh it is pretty thin
Wow as long as he doesn't break if the
needle if the thread breaks from I love
this angle this stare all day if the
thread breaks from a little bite I don't
think it's good enough for stitches just
how crista showed me oh this is gonna be
Nancy suing in your own body that's just
like I don't think that's illegal
[Music]
reacting god damn poor Kyle come on
Clements gonna be the new Arnold's
watching a game
I wouldn't I wouldn't do this I would
wait for the doctor to do it the day
after I would just get the peroxide to
make sure it doesn't get infected and
try to just hold it together or some
[ __ ] [ __ ] like that I don't know I'm
you cray that's all I'm saying
[Music]
hi god damn it again do it again
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
lacking love another time would sue
again and now they're banned ashes
toilet paper bang I mean I [ __ ] knew
it
are you [ __ ] Sammy oh you goddamn
Sammy this is my turf
oh [ __ ] my turf the fork that's the
[ __ ] get to four club oh gosh darn it
brick [ __ ] now the [ __ ]
oh this Mikey thing yeah baby what am i
doing what am i doing whatever hammer
have a damn good not to miss the same
thing great to know you how are you like
a new forehead it's only fifty bucks
there you go justice new a notes watchin
I know clammy Schwarzenegger alright
still not baby not bitten
I never was and you left me out here to
die you patched yourself up where'd you
get that stuff she deal form on this
doesn't change a thing she hasn't done
anything does this is the man not
carrying a baby
enough already you left me no choice you
could have just left
relax Rebecca no you [ __ ] locked me in
and how about that damn look at sneaking
around out here we better get inside you
hungry some tacos would be good but only
if Carlos makes him no tacos I guess I
hope you enjoyed
that's disgusting hope you bros enjoyed
another episode I think it's pretty cool
so far I like their whole Clementine
thing but leave a like if you enjoyed
watching I really appreciate it oh your
support especially with series like this
so thank you it's this kind of cover
today I'll see you in the next one
brofist bro
[Music]